six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
how about the three one two area code
caller from three one two if you can
hear me tell us who you are and what
your question is today hi I'm William
Pickering um I'm from Fox River Grove
and I had a not a really a direct
question but more of um I wanted to
clarify something from the serious side
of people not believing that like Russia
collusion didn't happen okay um even if
I even if I don't didn't particular
agree with it um it's that looking at
like what what what we're actually
helping Russia with like what have we
done for Russia since Trump has been
elected you're asking me or you want to
clarify that I'm it's sort of like a
question that like so like we haven't
approved like the UH like there was a
certain like billion dollar like
billions of dollars agreement that
didn't happen we put more sanctions on
Russia oh yeah so listen I mean it's
been 10 months right and there's two
sides to this one is that even without
actually doing anything for Russia if
Russia's geopolitical strategy is to put
themselves in a stronger position by
destabilizing American democracy helping
to get a total buffoon in is really
really useful to them and in fact if you
go back to the foundations of
geopolitics this book I've been talking
about it actually explains exactly why
Russia even if they didn't get anything
specific in exchange why it would still
be good for them to have Donald Trump in
office so that's number one and it
doesn't actually even require us to
pinpoint things we do know that
immediately well even before the
election of Donald Trump they started to
discuss the possible easing of sanctions
fortunately the House and Senate have
made that a little more difficult for
Trump but even the new sanctions that
they signed on to the Trump
administration is not actually enforcing
right so you're right there have been
used
sanctioned signed Trump administration
isn't enforcing them that's number one
number two immediately after being
inaugurated in January the Trump
administration started trying to figure
out how to get these two compounds
diplomatic compounds back to Russia
which had been which which they had been
kicked out of by the Obama
administration previously that's number
two number three we have the quid pro
quo that was intimated by Donald Trump
jr. in Trump Tower with the Russian
lawyer Natalya vessel nets kiya where he
basically said hey listen if you can get
us dirt on Hillary that helps Trump get
elected then we can look at revisiting
the Magnitsky law which relates to
Russian sanctions as well we now know
about that so I think that there's a lot
of different things that that we can
look at but again I don't actually think
that that matters because all of that
aside for geopolitical reasons Russia
would would relish having someone like
Donald Trump in the Oval Office all
right yeah um thanks for giving your
piece on that all right um thank you so
much appreciate it